One of the police officers charged in the
killing of George Floyd is Thomas Lane.
Thomas Lane has hired a lawyer named Earl
Gray.
And I can tell you, this guy is not at all
lemony and mild like Earl Gray tea.
He's actually quite the opposite.
And he imploded on live television last night.
He was interviewed by CNN's Chris Cuomo.
And Earl Gray tried to suggest that if bystanders
were really so concerned with how George Floyd
was being manhandled by police, why didn't
the bystanders jump in to restrain the police?
He actually says this and then he has no choice
but to back away from it.
When Chris Cuomo tells him how bonkers it
is, but if all these people say why, why didn't
my client intercede?
Well, if the public is there and they're so
in an uproar about this, they didn't intercede
either in my client's storm where you can't
really.
Hold on.
Counselor, counselor.
There's two things.
One is you're laying on a man's legs.
You've got a fine view of what's going on
with that man.
The other officer is literally a foot in front
of you on his neck, too.
I understand that he, as a senior officer,
telling him what to do.
But there's also a duty to intervene.
And he figured officer is doing something
that's dangerous to a civilian.
You have a duty to intervene.
And he did not intervene.
And the idea that the civilians should have
rushed in to a policing situation in the inner
city of Minneapolis against four police officers
that have weapons that are kneeling on the
neck of a man.
Don't you think that's asking a little much
of civilians and a little too little of your
client?
Absolutely, I am not.
I just brought that up.
Well, what would you say is I don't want to
weigh in.
Oh, he's got his feet.
He was holding his feet down.
Mr. King was off.
Searching was next.
And then Schavan.
So obviously, the suggestion of civilians
intervening against armed police is ridiculous.
And Earl Gray realized it and has to back
off and say, well, I'm merely bringing it
up.
Could this guy possibly be a good lawyer?
His defense of his client, Officer Thomas
Lane, was to ask, why didn't civilians commit
a crime?
Because if civilians actually go and try to
interfere with four armed officers in the
process of restraining and subsequently killing
George Floyd, they would have been arrested
and likely charged with interfering with law
enforcement.
Now, this is a good opportunity to step back
and give you a sense of in general how the
other officers, meaning the ones that were
not George, shot Derek Schavan, might approach
their defenses.
The idea is to say there was a power dynamic.
These guys like Thomas Lane, who is represented
by Attorney Air Earl Gray.
They were following orders.
They weren't really in a position because
of seniority differences to disagree, even
if they wanted to.
Now, here's our friend, Josh Campbell.
Campbell, former FBI agent, CNN reporter,
friend of the David Pakman show, asking Earl
Gray about is this the part?
Is the power dynamic thing, what you were
going with?
And Earl Gray didn't like it at all.
Take a look this.
Were you kind of applying a power dynamic
between the seniors on ask me, sir.
Right.
It is your Zirkin.
Is your claim that he was following orders,
your client claiming he was following orders
and what he was doing was right because he
has the trading officer.
Should we roll over place?
You've got to have criminal second degree
murder and rightfully so.
Earl Gray getting very upset there with a
pretty straightforward question from Josh
Campbell.
And then again, another example.
This is Earl Gray explaining.
My client couldn't really do anything.
I mean, he couldn't restrain Derek Schavan.
Take a look.
Be unreasonable for my client to go up and
try and drag Schavan off of.
Proces, Tony, you're a cop in the front and
my guys back to work for days.
Shall we roll them over?
And he says, no, we'll wait for the ambulance
twice.
And then he says he's suffering from a delirium.
I don't know what what you're supposed to
do as a cop.
So that's the gist of at least how Earl Gray
will seek to defend Thomas Lane's actions
in the killing of George Floyd.
He was only on the job a few days.
He didn't have the power dynamics on his side.
He did suggest rolling George Floyd over and
he couldn't really physically restrain Derek
Qof in any way, which is probably accurate.
He physically restraining Derek Schavan was
not a likely path.
So we've talked about many reforms, by the
way, but one that might benefit police is
to reorganize some of these sort of standards
of the chain of seniority.
There's a really interesting story that Malcolm
Gladwell tells in his book Outliers, nearly
12 years ago at this point about South Korean
pilots, which explained that South Korean
culture precluded co pilots from pointing
out to captains, hey, I'm seeing something
that doesn't look right and under that cultural
norm.
South Korean aviation was not particularly
safe.
And so South Korean Airlines retrained and
said, listen, the in the cockpit, we have
a different protocol than in Korean culture.
And first, officers not only should be allowed
to, but they should be encouraged to point
irregularities out to captains.
You won't be punished.
It's the right thing to do.
And when they reorganize that norm cultural
norm, in this case, South Korean aviation
became dramatically safer and much the same
way.
It is probably true that an officer on duty
for four days, this is not a defense of Thomas
Lane, but that one element is true in police
culture in the ranks.
It would be seen as inappropriate or unacceptable
to question the tactics of the senior officer
in that particular case.
That needs to be changed, and that is totally
separate from how any of these individual
charges are ultimately going to play out.
Let's take a quick break.
My interview with Neil Ferguson is next.
Make sure you're following The David Pakman
Show on Instagram at David Pakman.